now we've already heard on today's show
that any lockdown easing will be guided
by the data there are still
thousands of cases and hundreds of
deaths every day but things
do seem to be moving in the right
direction now as you can see
the number of daily cases is coming down
fluctuations of course but the blue line
that's the rolling
seven day average has clearly fallen
from the peak around christmas and new
year
so is the virus definitely receding and
what does it mean
for easing restrictions where we can ask
professor tim
specter from king's college at london uh
thank you very much for
uh being with us now your covert symptom
study app lets 4.5 million people report
their symptoms pretty comprehensive
database what is it showing in terms of
the virus and how many cases there are
currently
well the zoe app as we call it
colloquially as
has been showing that since the first of
january
cases have been falling across the
country
and the r value has really been
persistently below one during that time
and so we're now have uh
we've dropped by about 80 percent uh
since that time so
it currently means that um we're at a
similar state to where we were
in opt in october and
if we look at the trajectories of where
we're going
uh in a couple of weeks we're going to
be where we were
at the end of may beginning of june if
people can remember that far back
uh last year so that means that we'll be
below a prevalence which is the number
of people affected
uh have symptomatic covert of less than
one in five hundred
which uh in my view means that we should
be able to
reduce some of these restrictions uh and
i'm particularly concerned that we
uh get kids back to school as long as
possible because of the
known long-term uh negative effects of
that so
i'm the other the other consideration of
course is what's going on in the nhs and
that's what
people argue as a reason we shouldn't um
you know reduce these restrictions too
quickly and
the data are showing again
about a 60 drop in hospital admissions
and a about 50
drop in the number of percentage of
people who are in hospital with covid
uh since the worst worst of this which
was about the second week of january
so you mentioned it's looking quite good
you mentioned schools there
and we just spoke to mark drakeford
obviously in wales they are
reopening primary schools at a quicker
rate
than in england the prime minister said
that he hopes
to allow schools to reopen from the 8th
of march do you think it should be done
earlier than that then um
i think it's going to if it was up to me
i would say there are some regions where
it could be
opened up earlier particularly in rural
areas where they have very low rates of
disease and
particularly if you focused on the low
risk group which is the youngest
children who really pose very little
risk
to themselves or uh other people so
but i think to be honest if we had a
definite date of of the 8th of march
and we stuck to it i think most parents
around the country would be happy
because that would give them time to
prepare as well because
what people don't like is having sudden
switches in policy overnight
which can also uh cause problems yes
definitely when you're trying to kind of
prepare
home learning and obviously the teachers
as well the logistics of it too
and professor neil ferguson told me uh
this week that we could see low level
restrictions like
face mask wearing at big public
gatherings even into next year
do you think that's true or do you think
we could see a complete return to normal
earlier
my belief is that it isn't a yes no
scenario we're not going to suddenly
wake up one day and say
uh we're all cured you know like in the
hollywood movies
and uh wave flags
it's going to be a slow decrease out of
this
where we're going to have to need to be
cautious about new variants coming in
uh keeping an eye on how our vaccines
are doing
and so it makes sense to be sensible for
a while longer whilst still
keeping the vast majority of our social
life
and economic life and educational life
going so
um i've said before i see a scenario and
it's not necessarily what i want
and i get criticized whenever i mention
scenarios as does neil ferguson
but um i can see us
carrying on uh using masks in certain
situations
and why not have uh wash your hands
when you go to the supermarket or you're
touching food
these are things that other countries
routinely do if you look at japan
they do wear masks every winter
and it may not be compulsory it may
maybe but i think
this is the sort of scenario we're going
to see
but i'm also an optimist and i believe
that
we're going to drive the levels of this
virus really low
and the combination of uh also
the vaccine success and um i want to
come on and
if we can talk about that a bit as well
because well our app is also
showing us some very good data on the
vaccine what is the app showing on the
vaccine then
well so we've now got about a third of a
million people have logged their
first dose of a vaccine with us on the
zoe app
and anyone who's listening please if you
had a vaccine do
do logic log with us and we're showing
very low levels of side effects
and we show that after three weeks we're
getting
a 67 um
protection uh against the virus so
like three times less um
risk than you'd be you'd be getting
otherwise compared to uh unprotected
control so
that's much perhaps a better rate than
people had thought just on a single jab
and so i think that combined with the
data we're seeing
uh is gives me a lot of reason to be
optimistic
that we're going to be in a much better
place in
two to four weeks time and can start to
reduce some of these restrictions that's
really encouraging what kind of sample
size is it for
the vaccine data do you know well we've
analyzed about the first 50 000
uh people so it's a large sample and
these
are healthcare workers who are at high
risk so
they're the ones you would see changes
in most and
we're seeing a consistent fall that no
protection at all in the first two weeks
but and that's important for people to
notice because i think people rush out
and
think they're cured and there's high
risk of infection then we are seeing
lots of cases
but after two weeks it drops to about 46
and uh three weeks to six weeks it's 67
which is really great if that was around
the country
you know uh then we would have really
knocked this
virus on the head how do you work out
the 67 percent
uh we compare it to a group of control
uh
individuals who are healthcare workers
of the same age and sex
who have been logging with us and
haven't had the vaccine
so it's not the same as a a randomized
trial the data is not as clear-cut
but it's a real-life situation and this
often people say that
um the trials so over overestimate the
benefits of vaccines so
this is the first large-scale real uh
real-time data we have on on this of a
single jab
so it's still preliminary we're still
analyzing the results every week as
people give us more data
but it's it's just to say that it's
looking very promising and that the
the government's approach of delaying
the second
shot in order to get more people
vaccinated uh
looks like it's paying off now you
are able to report lots of different
symptoms on your
app and at the minute though you're only
many people are only
eligible for a clover test if you
display
a cough a fever or a loss of smell and
taste
now my producers always say that i
shouldn't use anything to do in my own
life because anecdotal but i recently
had covered and had none of those three
symptoms they wouldn't have been
eligible
for a test do you think the symptom
range needs to be expanded and is there
evidence that with the new variants
we're seeing different symptoms
well we've been saying since last spring
that the
the range of symptoms should be expanded
and this has been clear from
the people reporting on our app where
there are over 20 symptoms of covid that
are linked
and we've done uh we've published papers
and continues to do research saying the
same thing's happening is that 30
percent of people
who have a positive pcr test uh as
perhaps you did
do not have those three classic symptoms
and
this is particularly true in the first
three days of the illness
when it's most infectious so
i understand why we didn't do this last
spring because we didn't have any
testing
and it would have crashed the system
now we have a fantastic testing system
able to do over 600 000 tests a day
we do have the capacity to do it this is
the time to do that and we would reduce
infections by 30 in reality because
these people would be told to
stay at home at the moment it's you know
it's a real risk that we are ignoring
and all these smoke screens of testing
asymptomatic people
is far less productive than getting to
these people that
actually have symptoms and are spreading
the virus around so absolutely
um and i've forgotten your other
question
that was it i think that's all good oh i
did ask if the new variant
uh leads to different symptoms it's
interesting that
the the jury's out on this the the ons
uh
survey which is a similar size to us but
very different methodology
showed that there was more evidence of
headaches and fatigue
and um sort of sore throats
uh whereas our data which has been
consistent since since the beginning
has shown no difference so uh i i think
we don't know yet
i think we need to keep a close eye on
it but if everyone was more aware
that you know the two common symptoms of
early covid are headache and fatigue and
sort
and then you've got sore throat and sore
muscles then
actually everyone would be safer so i
think it's it's a good debate to keep
going on and keep looking at
now you said recently that you don't
watch the number 10 news conferences
anymore
why not um
well i i i've overdone on covert stats i
guess
and i also um i i also
get a bit disheartened by the fact that
we only focus on certain of those
statistics so
the fact that not just the number 10 but
also the media
focus on the number of deaths that day
and i think it's a very misleading
statistic
because um i can't know whether
it's very sad people die of anything
but for example yesterday around 600
people died of covid
but uh on a normal
uh day in february 1500 people would die
mostly of heart disease strokes um
cancer etc so or the flu
so we never put those statistics into
any
uh context and i think this has got a
lot of people
extremely anxious um and
you know are petrified to leave their
homes and may have real problems
coming out again if we don't put these
stats
into some real perspective that yes
rates are high people are dying from
covid but they also die from other
things
many of those people are not seeking
help in the nhs
they are having mental health problems
uh they're not getting their cancer
looked at
not looking after their heart etc so i
just would like to see
also uh perhaps less
fear-mongering and more a general
picture and that's
oh we've just lost you um we did get uh
through most of the interview though uh
fascinating stuff professor
tim spector there uh from kings the
founder of the zoe app